-We're hanging out
with Jon Hamm!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The greatest.
His new movie,
"No Sudden Move,"
begins streaming on HBO Max
on July 1st.
And now Jon and I
are about to go head-to-head
in a game of
egg Russian roulette.
Higgins, would you like
to explain how this works?
-[Speaking evilly]
Yes, James!
Here in my hands
I have one dozen eggs.
Four thrice.
Eight of them --
[ Laughter ]
-Four thrice. Yeah.
-Okay.
-Eight of them --
-Keep going.
-That is two and four --
have been hard-boiled.
Four of them...are still raw!
You and Jon shall take turns
selecting an egg
and smashing it upon your head.
You won't know
which eggs are raw
and which ones are hard-boiled.
But once you choose an egg,
you must smash that egg!
-Should you be in a costume
or something?
-I know.
Acting. Know what I mean?
-Can we put it back?
-Yeah.
No. You may not. No putbacks.
-Okay!
-Can we take two?
-No, you may not.
Wh-one egg! Wh-one egg!
Either r-r-raw or hard-buhled.
As a guest of the show, Jon,
you shall proceed
with the prima ovum.
The first egg.
-The prima ova. [ Laughs ]
-Which one shall you choose?
-Primum ovum?
-Prima! Prima ovum.
[ Laughs evilly ]
-How do you feel -- Ooh.
[ Gasps ] Oh! The spin trick!
Wait. I feel good
about that one.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-You were so confident!
You were so confident!
-[ Laughs evilly ]
-You were so confident,
and you -- you were acting.
-The yoke's on you, Mr. Hamm!
[ Chortling ]
James! I hope you don't
get egg on your...shirt.
-Oh, boy.
-I like what you --
I see what you did there.
-Oh! That one?
Mistake. Mm, yes.
-I feel good about it.
-Buena fortun-a-a-a-a!
-Solid. Solid.
-It's a solid one.
-Solid. I can see it.
-I can feel it. Thanks.
It has a sheen to it.
-Well. Charlie or Martin?
-Um -- [ Laughs ]
UH, Emilio.
-Emilio Estevez.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sheens all over. [ Laughs ]
Ooh. Nice selection there.
-I shall not look.
-No, you can look, Higgins.
It doesn't matter if you see it.
-Pick an egg.
There are still three raw eggs.
-Jon, if you pick --
-Ohh!
-My hand's all eggy.
It's slippery.
-There you go. Good luck.
That served you well last time.
-Wow.
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I learned that
from Encyclopedia Brown.
-Oh! That's the movie --
-Lower the air in the tires,
and you can get an inch.
Good luck, James. Good luck!
-He's confident.
The confidence is solid.
You feel it. I feel good.
-Hey, come on, kid. Let's play
catch around the backyard.
[ Talking over each other ]
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Getting to be a pro at this.
-You are batting a thousand.
-I am batting a thou.
-Three remain...
-[ Shudders ]
-...unfettered by heat.
Raw in the st-- Oh.
♪♪
-I'm not gonna spin it.
-You're not?
-No.
-All right.
But it looks like you are.
-Well, I'm not.
-All right.
-I mean, I might roll it.
-Okay.
And what were you doing --
Like, "Ehh..."
[ Speaking gibberish ]
Hah!
-Ohh!
[ Bell dinging ]
-Thank you so much for --
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much
for coming on the show.
Jon Hamm! He's unbelievable!
That's --
[ Cheers and applause ]